we're on demand laundry and dry cleaning
company actually people describe us as
being the uber of laundry and actually
the idea came about from our Chairman
actually who approached us with the idea
of creating a digital business within
the laundry and dry cleaning industry
and I guess the rest is history the
business is still fairly early stage
which is 24 months old but actually over
the last 24 months we've seen
exponential growth and just to be clear
long drop is you're a technology company
you don't actually own any of this this
is what's going on behind us here you
partnering with them so just like
companies like uber or delivery
we don't own any of the facilities or
the machinery we own the technology and
the platform and that basically means
that a business like ours can grow
exponentially how do you think has it
been to roll out nationally and get
national coverage for what you're doing
we're currently operational across about
a hundred towns and cities across the UK
in just a 24 month period so we've been
switching live a city or town at the
rate of approximately about one every
two weeks
today we're now live in Australia New
Zealand and over the next 12 months
we'll be launching in a further 13 or 14
other countries around the world the
beauty of a business like laundry and
the way that we've developed our
technology is that it's infinitely
scalable
across the world how do you identify
some of your partners I mean this looks
quite a harsh working environment there
are signs up warning the workers that
they can be fine for various things how
do you monitor who you're working with
we have about 30 or 40 partners across
the entire UK and these partners are
very very carefully vetted we have
hundreds and hundreds of people if not
thousands of people that want to work
with lawn drop therefore yes we're very
very careful in terms of doing our due
diligence on making sure that we're
working with the right partners a lot of
concerns about whether it's going to be
easy to attract talent post brexit is
that on your mind lawn drop employs
around 50 or 60 people in the business
and approximately about 70 percent of
those people are overseas workers and
actually we don't believe the the brexit
situation will impact us at all and if
anything actually post referendum our
business has been
even faster than before you're comparing
yourselves with uber could your business
model withstand a change in the labor
laws of the time that uber are being
threatened with so unlike other
companies that use zero hour contracts
we decided at the very beginning that we
wouldn't do that so all of the employees
and from the from the drivers through to
all of our office based staff are all
employees of our business and what's the
competitive landscape right now our
biggest competitor for law drop is the
home washing machine actually we have a
mantra which is we want to take Ward's
of the washing machine and change
consumer opinion and behavior around
doing their home domestic laundry what
we see in this space much like we've
seen in the the takeaway industry or
even with with with taxi companies like
uber is that consumer behavior is now
shifting very very quickly thanks to
smart phone technology and we believe
that the laundry industry is the next
industry ripe for disruption everyone
talked about London being the UK
technology hub euro Bristol boy could
you set up the business in a in a city
like Bristol I would have loved nothing
more of them to have set this business
up in Bristol but the fact is I don't
think the infrastructure and and
certainly the investment is necessarily
there and if only because of the
investment it means that many many
companies unfortunately or maybe
fortunately are often drawn into central
London